on the season finale of Rick and Morty
mr. president some kind of alien Booga
has infested the Kennedy sex tunnels
I wanted hunted down and taken out
Kennedy sex tunnels naturally you'll
forget you saw them along with in order
of national embarrassment the Truman
cocaine lounge the McKinley hooker dump
and the Lincoln slave Coliseum he didn't
free them all the season finale of Rick
and Morty next Sunday at 11:30 only on
Adult Swim
everybody we got new Rick and Morty
finale to talk about so there are a
whole bunch of Easter eggs in that promo
but I know a lot of you are like okay so
they're bringing back the get schwifty
president because they said the Keith
David will be coming back but what about
evil Morty who's now the president of
the council of ricks so I'll try to
address that in the video because if
there's anything we've learned about
Rick and Morty promos is that they're
very misleading and they don't tell you
everything that's happening in an entire
episode so if you're finding me for the
first time I will be doing Rick and
Morty videos every week during the off
season be sure to subscribe to get
everything and there will be like weekly
merch giveaways too I'll explain at the
end of the video but if you haven't
listened to the commentary from the get
schwifty episode the whole reason why
Dan Harmon and Justin roiland created
the US president in Rick's relationship
with him is sort of a parody on the
third doctor from Doctor Who's
relationship with the US government back
during the early 70s something that
doctor who did it just introduced this
like leftenant character who would call
Doctor Who from time to time
Doctor Who could be just off fighting
Daleks and googas and things and like
then every eight episode just some
British dude that worked for the
military wouldn't call Doctor Who back
to earth and go like we need your help
fighting the Loch Ness monster and
that's what I think of this president
character so that was sort of the
impetus for the get schwifty episode
with the Crimea Lon's like oh we got to
call in rick because he's the only one
that can handle a problem with this
magnitude so it sounds like they wanted
to bring keith david back because he's
fantastic and the gates 50 episode was
great so they're using this to poke fun
at a lot of the most famous US
presidents it why like all the funny
things the president says they're
supposed to forget like the kennedy sex
tunnels the truman cocaine lounge the
McKinley hooker dump in the Lincoln
slave Coliseum most of those presidents
on that list were assassinated in office
shout-out to aber Dolph link ler we
haven't seen him in a while they keep
talking about him but we don't know when
he's coming back either you may
recognize the janitor getting killed by
the googas while sweeping those tunnels
is Mike McMahan he's one of the writers
in real life you see him in all those
behind the scenes promos that they
release after the episodes they always
work themselves in in the background
every once in a while Justin roiland was
in the classroom in this past episode
they even turned GU Terman into one of
the Morty's in the background in that
strip club during the council of ricks
episode but if you're asking why they're
still doing the get schwifty president
on the TV show if we had a u.s. election
there should be a new president in the
Rick and Morty universe it's probably
because they wrote this episode way
before the u.s. election last year
because animation takes a long time to
complete so they'd probably already
decided to bring Keith David back they
wrote the episode they sent it off to
get animated with animatics they'd
already done a whole bunch of work on it
then the US election happened last
November so like by the time that all
went down they were already well into
production on this episode in the whole
point of the episode isn't necessarily
to parody the president is really just
to bring Keith David back so that they
could do this funny story about previous
US presidents so sometimes that'll
happen when there's a big US election
but a lot of TV shows do presidential
episodes sometimes they'll just choose
to ignore the actual election and just
do their own thing but right off the bat
he drops a couple big Easter eggs so he
says there are some googas infecting the
kennedy sex tunnels you may remember
that gugus was one of the channel 101
skits that Dan Harmon had Justin roiland
it it was one of their first big skits
together this is a little clip from that
what the hell are these crazy cuckoo cos
right that's what we're gonna call them
I'm saying one thing we're gonna call
the cops we gotta call the army I mean
this is like Ghoulies out there what if
the cops come in harder what if this is
not like Ghoulies but it's like our
mouth was adorable
this is ghuli this is like al fuli's
we're like party of five
that was from almost 10 years ago so
that's why they look so different but
googas are just like these creatures
from outer space within this channel 101
schizo they're just bringing that to
Rick and Morty they've used the googas
as easter eggs in previous episodes
before - but I feel like if you're a US
government conspiracy theorist this
episode was built for you like there are
secret tunnels underneath the White
House but there's just like a secret
bunker but people always believe you
know there's all kinds of things built
underground the president built all
kinds of tunnels so that he could get
around Kennedy sex tunnels so that he go
have sex with all these women that he
was with but it'll be fun to see how
Rick and Morty treats stuff like that
the interesting thing about the title
though getting into evil Morty territory
the Rick turian Morty date is sort of a
play on the idea of The Manchurian
Candidate where you basically have
somebody who's trying to be elected US
president but he's being controlled by
communists that's the classic movie it's
sort of a Cold War conspiracy tale like
where they basically brainwashed
somebody and try to get him elected
president so that the Communists could
control the United States by controlling
the President so nowhere in this promo
does anybody seem like they've been
brainwashed that might have something to
do with the googas that might have
something to do with the Galactic
Federation because we still haven't seen
Phoenix person or Tammie come back yet
or it might even have something to do
with evil Morty just remember that the
promos that they've released this season
so far primarily the Atlantis promo was
completely misleading so just be
prepared for a whole lot of other stuff
to be happening in the episode besides
what you see in this little clip here
but also in that same vein they do set
things up in previous seasons that they
don't completely answer like evil Marty
back at the end of season one he just
goes off into the distance he walks away
and you don't know
happens - till you get to season 3
episode 7 it was this interview that I
posted a little while ago where Justin
roiland talks about threads that they
have like oh we set up a bunch of
threads that we can pick up on later if
we want to I've said this a couple of
times today I think that like we've left
a lot of sweater threads is that it
sweater or little loose ends a little
little dangly dangly dangles that we're
gonna come back to we're no rush so in
the off chance that we don't see any
evil Morty or there's no post credit
scene or nothing addressing the big WTF
moments of the season that we're just
kind of left hanging like oh my god
what's going to happen now they could
just leave stuff like that for season
four but for those of you asking why
they haven't made any official season
four announcements yet they actually
have been in the office working on Rick
and Morty and if the finale is done then
I ask you what are they doing in the
rick and morty office
normally when season's finished they'll
pitch ideas for the next season they'll
start writing some outlines and then
they'll go on a hiatus for a couple
weeks and then come back and start
writing the next season again so one of
the writers posted a picture of the rick
and morty office from yesterday
so like literally they've finished
writing the finale a while ago they
delivered it usually the last thing they
do on episodes is that the music to it
like after the animation is done after
they ADR some of the dialogue like
justin roiland sometimes has to go back
in after episodes are done and fix some
of the dialogue if it doesn't sound as
good as they want it to so once that's
all done then they ship it off so that's
been done on the finale for a while so
if the writers are still in the rick and
morty writers room it's probably because
they're starting to write season four I
haven't seen anything official about
that so like I couldn't say oh they're X
number of episodes deep into the season
or they have outlines for X number of
season four episodes but hopefully if
they work all the business stuff with
their contracts out behind the scenes
because Justin roiland a Dan Harmon
we're working on contract renewals for
future seasons of Rick and Morty they
really want to make it it's just like
the business stuff behind the scenes and
how they get paid and all that stuff
needed to be worked out like
productively Justin and I we're gonna
figure out how to make season four
faster more efficient how we're gonna
put the hood on that creative process
and like you know help you help we're
gonna do it help ourselves like generate
Rick and Marty so much faster that
season four can premier up to two hours
after season three so even though
they're not quite done with that yet
they probably started working on season
four stuff just anticipating that
everything would work out and they'd
roll things along and get season four
out by next year so there wouldn't be
like a huge year and a half two year
wait like there was last time but if I
hear anything official about that or if
they drop any clues then I'll totally
post a video about it and I'll be doing
videos during the off season every week
so it'll be a mixture of Theory videos
bonus videos from the season Easter eggs
and then obviously any big news that
they drop or any bonus features and then
I'll be doing DVD giveaways too but they
haven't announced when they're releasing
the season 3 DVD that probably be
sometime next year
so whenever they do announce that I'll
start doing the giveaways for the DVDs
but all you have to do to enter the
giveaway just be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video congratulations to
the winner from my last video ultra nerd
you win a copy of one of the new art
books please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there'll be a new round
when I post new rick and morty later
this week so you can click here for more
Easter eggs and you can click here for
my video all about Rick's wife thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]